in the last few videos we've been
talking about the production
possibilities frontiers a relatively
static thing something that you couldn't
change but you could move along what i
want to do in this video is think about
maybe there are ways to change or expand
the production possibilities frontier
and to do that let's assume that our
little hunter-gatherer has decided to
become a strict carnivore so he's only
focused on rabbits now and his whole
happiness in life is optimizing the
number of rabbits he can catch and eat
in a given day and so
let's on one axis let's draw
let's say the number of rabbits that he
can catch in a given day so let's say
it's one
two
three
four
five
six
seven i could keep going on and on so
this right over here is rabbits
rabbits that he can catch in a given day
rabbits in a day but remember he wants
to optimize this he wants to think about
how he can increase his productivity of
in terms of the number of rabbits and he
knows we'll just assume that he knows
how to build rabbit traps so now we're
going to do a production possibilities
frontier not between rabbits and berries
but between rabbits and
building rabbit traps so rabbit traps
rabbit traps so maybe some type of he's
able to get twigs together and you know
he builds something puts the twigs
together in a little thing you know it's
a little box
that maybe he puts a little i don't know
some type of carrot down over there and
then if the rabbit comes then takes the
carrot then the box falls on the rabbit
or something like that we don't we don't
have to go into the particulars of the
actual trap but he can also spend his
time building rabbit traps so let's say
so it's one rabbit trap two rabbit traps
and three rabbit traps and let's say
we're going to hold all other things
equal ceteris paribus so we're not
worrying about other things and as we'll
see in in most introductory economics
class whenever you do a production
possibilities frontier you're only doing
it with two dimensions and so that's why
you have a regular curve you could have
one with three dimensions where you're
doing the trade-off between three things
but then you would have to have a
three-dimensional
graph and essentially the production
possibilities frontier would be a
surface but let's just function focus on
this right now maybe i'll do a surface
in the future just for fun so this are
the rabbit traps and let's say the the
production possibilities frontier
between rabbit traps and rabbits look
something like this he could spend all
his time making rabbit traps but in that
case he won't get any rabbits and he'll
probably starve and that wouldn't be a
good scenario or he could spend all of
his time hunting for rabbits and he
would catch on average five rabbits per
day but that would leave him no time to
make rabbit traps so this is our current
production possibilities
let me
let me just draw it
this is our current production
possibilities frontier so i'll call this
p production possibilities frontier and
i'll put a little a little zero
subscript there that's our starting
point so he could he could sit anywhere
over here and he would have achieved
productive efficiency anywhere on this
curve but as we saw if he just spent all
of his time if he just spent all of his
time doing this over here he'll never
get any rabbit traps and so he won't be
able to change the productive
possibility frontier but what happens if
instead he decides that he does want to
build some rabbit traps so he decreases
the number of rabbits a day to four and
though that allows him to make one
rabbit trap per day so he wants to hang
out in this scenario
so every day that goes by on average
he's going to make four rabbits and he's
going to build a rabbit trap so what's
going to happen so as we go into the
maybe into the next period he would now
have a rabbit trap
after just one day that he can use to
help catch rabbits so that will actually
change the production possibilities
frontier so if he makes this investment
it will actually allow him in a given
amount of time to actually catch more
rabbits so if he does that the
production possibilities frontier having
a rabbit trap won't make him that much
won't allow him to make more rabbit
traps in a day so the most rabbit traps
he can make in a day is still going to
be three
but maybe now he can catch six rabbits a
day
so it might look something
like
like that
so now he could either stop making
rabbit traps and catch six a day just
with that one rabbit trap he has or he
could continue he could continue that
and now actually he can catch five
rabbits a day and still make one rabbit
trap a day and maybe he decides to do
that but it could be anywhere along this
production possibilities frontier so he
could say or he could say hey you know
i'm happy making eating the four rabbits
a day i'm going to make two rabbit traps
now
every day and now after another period
he gets even more productive and so then
the production so let me call let me
call this one
this is after one day production
possibilities frontier after one day
and then after two days let's say he did
this scenario right over here now he's
produced two rabbit traps and obviously
this is maybe i'm exaggerating how
quickly his productivity would grow but
maybe now the new production
possibilities frontier looks like looks
something like this he now has two
rabbit traps
so or he matched two more rabbit traps
he already had once now he has three
rabbit traps after two days and so now
if you want to devote himself purely to
rabbit trapping he can get eight rabbits
a day or he could do some combination in
between and actually this curve it
shouldn't go up at all i don't want to
give you the impression that it went up
and then down it just goes kind of
straight it does something like that
right over here so this right over here
i'll call that the production
possibilities frontier 2.
so what this hunter-gatherer is doing in
this scenario right here is he is making
an investment he is making an investment
he is accumulating capital this right
over here this is capital
he is he is choosing instead of to
consume all of his resources so there's
two things he can do he can either spend
all of his time in pure consumption
getting as many rabbits as possible a
day and then eating them all pure
consumption or he could reduce his
consumption and then allocate some of
his resources towards investment so this
right over here this is an investment
this is an investment it makes him more
productive this right over here is
consumption there's some base level of
consumption he needs to survive but if
he invests then it increases his overall
productive capacity so if you viewed him
as an economy by himself
by investing instead of consuming all of
his resources by investing some of his
resources in this case his resources are
his time his expertise by investing some
of them he's able to increase his
productivity and if you view them as an
economy he's experiencing economic
economic
economic growth and so there's multiple
types of investments and we'll talk
about about these in multiple videos
in this case he is doing capital
accumulation he is building tools that
will make him more productive
another type of investment is
essentially technological change
technological improvement which would
actually make his tools even better so
we could have a we could maybe draw
another production possibilities
frontier between making rabbit traps and
then doing r d on inventing new types of
rabbit traps and so he could decide
which of those two things he wants to
decide between but what i wanted you to
just appreciate in this video is that
the production possibilities frontier
can change you can become more
productive if you do have investment in
r d or capital accumulation and in this
case that just happened to be rabbit
traps